Albert me da instrucciones: "Empújalo hasta arriba".
Lo hago.
"Empújalo más arriba".
Los testículos emergen, se ven como pulgares, apuntando hacia tí.
Y dice: "Muérdelos,
sólo muérdelos".
Y lo oí, oí cada palabra.
(Risas)
¿Cómo es que llegué aquí?
¿Cómo es que --ya saben, quiero decir--
cómo es que llegué aquí?
(Risas)
Es sólo... es uno de esos momentos
cuando el cerebro se desconecta por sí solo
y de repente, estoy de pie ahí en las Rocallosas,
y todo lo que puedo pensar es
en la definición aristotélica de una tragedia.
Ya saben, Aristóteles dijo que una tragedia
es ese momento cuando el héroe se enfrenta con su verdadera identidad.
(Risas)
Y pienso: ¿Qué significa esta jodida metáfora?
No me gusta lo que estoy pensando.
Y no puedo quitarme este pensamiento de mi cabeza,
y no puedo quitarme esa visión de mi vista,
así que hice lo que tenía que hacer.
Entré y los tomé.
Los tomé así,
y tiré mi cara hacia atrás.
Y estoy ahí parado
con dos testículos en mi barbilla.
(Risas)
Y ahora no puedo... no puedo quitarme la metáfora.
Bien, sigo con la poesía, con Aristóteles,
y de la nada, se me aparecen dos términos en mi cabeza
que no oía desde que mi profesor de griego las metió ahí
y estos son anagnórisis y peripecia.
Anagnórisis y peripecia.
Anagnórisis es la palabra griega para descubrimiento.
Literalmente, la transición de ignorancia a sabiduría es anagnórisis,
lo que nuestro canal de TV hace,
es lo que Trabajo Sucio es.
Y estoy hasta la coronilla de anagnórisis todos los días.
Estupendo.
La otra palabra, peripecia,
ese es el momento en las grandes tragedias, ya saben,
Euripides y Sófocles,
el instante que Edipo tiene su momento,
donde de repente se da cuenta que esa chica sensual
con la que ha estado acostándose y teniendo bebés es su madre.
Eso es "peripetía"
o peripecia.
Y con esta metáfora en mi cabeza
tengo anagnórisis y peripecia en mi barbilla.
(Risas)
Les tengo que decir, es un gran dispositivo.
Cuando comienzas a buscar a peripecia
la encuentras en todos lados.
Quiero decir, Bruce Willis en "El Sexto Sentido", ¿cierto?
Se pasa toda la película tratando de ayudar al niño que ve gente muerta,
y luego, pum --ay, estoy muerto-- peripecia.
¿Ya saben?
Es aplastante cuando la audiencia lo ve de la manera correcta.
Neo en la película "Matrix"
Ay, vivo en un programa de computadora, esto es extraño.
Estos descubrimientos que llevan a elucidar de repente,
los he tenido en más de 200 trabajos sucios, todo el tiempo,
pero ese, me clavó algo muy profundo y a lo no estaba preparado.
Y, mientras estaba de pie ahí,
viendo al cordero feliz al que acababa de desflorar,
pero que se veía bien.
En comparación al otro pobre que había tratado correctamente
y estaba apabullado
porque si estoy equivocado acerca de eso
y si estoy equivocado tan a menudo, tan cabalmente
¿de qué otros conceptos equivocados podría comentar?
Porque, miren, no soy antropólogo social
pero tengo un amigo que lo es.
Y hablo con él.
(Risas)
Y el dice: "Oye Mike.
Mira, no sé si tu cerebro se interesa en esta clase de cosas,
¿pero te das cuenta de que has filmado en cada estado?
Has trabajado en minas, has trabajado en la pesca,
has trabajado en el acero, en cada industria importante.
Has trabajado hombro a hombro con estos hombres
con quienes nuestros políticos desesperadamente
se relacionan cada cuatro años, ¿sí?
Veo a Hillary con los tragos de whisky,
que le escurren por el mentón con los obreros.
Quiero decir, estas son las personas con las que trabajo a diario.
Y si tienes algo qué decir acerca de sus pensamientos, colectivamente,
podría ser el momento de pensar en ello.
Porque, saben, son cuatro años.
Saben, eso está en mi cabeza, los testículos están en mi barbilla,
los pensamientos brincan alrededor.
Y, después de esa filmación, Trabajo Sucio realmente no cambió,
en términos de lo que es el programa,
pero cambió para mí, personalmente.
Y ahora, cuando hablo del programa,
ya no sólo hablo de la historia que oyeron y de 190 más como esa.
Lo hago, pero también hablo de otras cosas en las que me equivoqué,
algunas de las otras ideas del trabajo
que he estado suponiendo como sacrosantas,
y no lo son.
Las personas con trabajos sucios son más felices de lo que piensan.
Como grupo, son las personas más felices que conozco.
No quiero comenzar a silbar "Busca la Etiqueta del Sindicato"
y esa mierda del trabajador feliz.
Sólo digo que son personas equilibradas
que hacen trabajos impensables.
Los recogedores de animales muertos
silban mientras trabajan, lo juro por Dios,
lo hice con ellos.
Tienen esta increible simetría hacia su vida
y lo veo una y otra y otra vez.
Así que comencé a preguntarme que sucedería
si retaramos algunas de estas vacas sagradas.
Sigue tu pasión...
hemos estado hablando de esto aquí las últimas 36 horas.
Sigue tu pasión, ¿qué hay de malo en eso?
Probablemente el peor consejo que he recibido.
(Risas)
Saben, sigue tus sueños y quiebra, ¿cierto?
Me explico, eso es todo lo que oía cuando crecía.
No sabía qué hacer con mi vida,
pero me dijeron que si seguía mi pasión, iba a funcionar.
Les puedo dar 30 ejemplos, ahora mismo,
Bob Combs, el granjero de puercos en Las Vegas,
quien recoge los restos de comida de los casinos
y se los da a sus puercos.
¿Por qué? Porque hay tanta proteína en lo que no nos comemos
que sus puercos crecen al doble de lo normal
y es un granjero de puercos adinerado,
que es bueno para el medio ambiente,
y pasa sus días dando este servicio increible;
huele a rayos, pero Dios lo bendiga.
Vive muy bien.
Pregúntale: "¿Seguiste tu pasión?"
y se reirá de tí.
Al hombre le acaban de ofrecer como 60 millones de dólares por su granja
y los rechazó, fuera de Las Vegas.
Él no siguó su pasión.
Dio un paso atras y vio a donde se dirigian todos
y él se fue en la otra dirección.
Y oigo esa historia una y otra vez.
Matt Froind, un granjero lechero en New Canaan, Connecticut,
que despertó un día y se dio cuenta que la mierda de sus vacas
valía más que su leche,
si pudiera usarla para hacer estas macetas biodegradables.
Ahora se las vende a Walmart.
¿Siguió su pasión? El tipo... por favor.
Así que comencé a examinar la pasión,
comencé a examinar eficiencia versus efectividad,
así como Tim habló con anterioridad, hay una gran diferencia.
Comencé a examinar el trabajo en equipo y la determinación,
y básicamente todas esos lugares comunes a los que llaman "éxito-accesorios"
que cuelgan con ese arte cursi en las salas de consejo del mundo.
Esas cosas...
han sido repentinamente puestas de cabeza.
Seguridad, ¿primero la seguridad?
Volviendo a la Admón. de Seguridad y Salud Ocupacional OSHA
y PETA y la Sociedad Humana.
¿Y si OSHA está equivocada?
Lo que estoy a punto de decirles herejía,
pero ¿qué tal si en realidad la seguridad es lo tercero?
¿Sí?
(Risas)
No, quiero decir,
lo que quiero decir es que valoro mi seguridad en estos trabajos locos
tanto como las personas con quienes trabajo.
pero los que en realidad lo hacen,
no están allá afuera hablando que la seguridad es primero.
Ellos saben que otras cosas vienen primero,
el negocio de hacer las cosas viene primero,
el negocio de hacerlo.
Nunca olvidaré, allá en el Mar de Bering, estaba en un bote cangrejero
con la gente del programa "Pesca Mortal",
con quienes trabajé en la primera temporada.
Estábamos a más de 150 km de la costa de Rusia,
olas grandes de 15 metros, agua verde pasando por arriba de la cabina, ¿sí?
El ambiente más peligroso que jamás haya visto,
y estaba con un tipo, atando las trampas.
Así que estoy 12 metros por arriba de la cubierta,
que es como si estuvieras viendo la punta de tu zapato,
saben, y se hace así en el océano.
Inexplicablemente peligroso.
Corro hacia abajo y me meto a la cabina
y digo, con cierto nivel de incredulidad,
"Capitán, OSHA".
Y él dice, "¿OSHA? Océano".
Y apunta allá afuera.
(Risas)
En ese momento, lo que dijo a continuación
no puede ser repetido en los 48 estados contiguos.
No puede ser repetido en ninguna fábrica o construcción.
Pero me vió, y dijo, "Hijo,
es de mi edad pero me llama hijo, me encanta esto,
me dice: "Hijo, soy el capitán de un bote cangrejero,
mi responsabilidad no es llevarte a casa vivo.
mi responsabilidad es llevarte a casa rico".
(Risas)
Quieres llegar vivo a casa, eso te toca a tí.
Y por el resto del día, la seguridad fue lo primero.
Yo estaba como...
la idea de que creamos este falso,
este sentido de complacencia
cuando todo lo que hacemos es hablar de la responsabilidad de otro
como si fuera la nuestra y viceversa.
Como sea, muchas otras cosas lo son.
Podría hablar extensamente de las pequeñas distinciones que hacemos
y de la interminable lista de mis muchas equivocaciones
Pero a lo que nos lleva todo esto, es
que formé una teoría y la voy a compartir ahora
en los dos minutos y 30 segundos que me quedan.
Dice así,
le hemos declarado la guerra al trabajo,
como sociedad, todos nosotros.
Es una guerra civil.
Es una guerra fría, realmente.
No nos la propusimos
y no nos torcimos nuestro bigote de una manera maquiavélica,
pero la hemos hecho.
Y hemos llevado a cabo esta guerra en por lo menos cuatro frentes,
por supuesto en Hollywood.
La manera en que retratamos a los trabajadores en la TV
es risible.
Si tienes un plomero, pesa 136 kilos
y tiene una gigantesca raja en el culo, admítanlo.
Lo ven todo el tiempo.
Así es como se ven a los plomeros, ¿cierto?
Los convertimos en héroes o en fracasados.
Eso es lo que hace la TV.
En Trabajo Sucio trabajamos muy duro para no hacer eso,
por esa razón hago el trabajo y no hago trampa.
Pero, hemos llevado a cabo esta guerra en Madison Avenue.
Quiero decir, muchos de los anuncios que salen de ahí,
a manera de mensaje, ¿qué dicen en realidad?
Tu vida sería mejor si pudieras trabajar un poco menos,
si no tuvieras que trabajar tan duro, y llegar a casa un poco más temprano,
si pudieras retirarte un poco más rápido, salir del trabajo un poquito antes,
ahí está todo, una y otra vez.
Washington, no puedo siquiera hablar de los pactos y políticas existentes
que afectan la realidad de los trabajos disponibles
porque realmente no lo sé.
Sólo sé que ese es un frente en esta guerra.
Y justo aquí amigos, en Sillicon Valley,
quiero decir, ¿cuánta gente tiene un iPhone ahora mismo?
¿Cuánta gente tiene su Blackberry?
Estamos enchufados, conectados.
Nunca sugeriría ni por un segundo
que algo malo ha salido de la revolución tecnológica.
Por favor, no a esta multitud.
(Risas)
Pero diría que la innovación sin imitación
es una pérdida completa de tiempo.
Y nadie celebra la imitación
de la manera que la gente de Trabajo Sucio sabe que se tiene que hacer.
Tu iPhone sin esta gente que hace la misma interfaz,
los mismos circuitos, las mismas tarjetas, una y otra vez.
Todo eso, eso es lo que lo hace igualmente posible
que el genio que va dentro de él.
Así que, tenemos esta caja de herramientas nueva, saben.
Nuestras herramientas de hoy no se ven como palas y picos.
Se ven como las cosas con las que caminamos.
Y así el efecto colectivo de todo eso
ha sido la marginalización de muchos y muchos trabajos.
Y me di cuenta, quizá muy tarde en este juego,
espero que no, pues no sé si pueda hacer 200 más de estas cosas,
pero haremos tantas como podamos.
Y para mí lo más importante
y de verdad encontrarme cara a cara con ello,
es el hecho de que me equivoqué acerca de muchas cosas,
no sólo de los testículos en mi barbilla.
Estaba equivocado en muchas cosas.
Asi que pensamos --por nosotros, quiero decir yo -
que debemos hablar de una campaña de relaciones públicas por el trabajo,
el trabajo manual, el trabajo especializado.
Alguien necesita estar allá afuera
y hablar de los beneficios olvidados,
hablar de las cosas de los abuelos,
cosas con las que quizá muchos de nosotros crecimos
pero que hemos, ya saben, hemos perdido
un poco.
Barack quiere crear 2.5 millones de trabajos.
La infrestructura es un asunto enorme.
Esta guerra con el trabajo, que supongo existe, tiene bajas
como en cualquier guerra.
La infraestrcutura es la primera,
el declive de inscripciones
a escuelas profesionales es la segunda.
Cada año, hay menos electricistas,
menos carpinteros, menos plomeros,
menos soldadores, menos tuberos,
menos vaporeros.
Los trabajos de infraestructura de los que todo mundo habla de crear
son estos tipos.
Los que van en declive, una y otra vez.
Mientras tenemos 2 billones de dólares, como mínimo,
según la Sociedad Americana de Ingenieros Civiles,
que requerimos gastar para sólo mejorar un poco la infraestructura
que tiene actualmente una calificación deficiente.
Así que, si buscara un puesto político y no lo busco,
simplemente diría que los trabajos que esperamos hacer
y los que esperamos crear
no van a perdurar si no son los trabajos que la gente quiere.
Y sé que el propósito de esta conferencia
es para celebrar las cosas que son más cercanas a nosotros,
pero también sé que limpio y sucio no son opuestos.
Son dos lados de una misma moneda,
justo como innovación e imitación,
como riesgo y responsabilidad,
como peripecia y anagnórisis,
como ese pobre corderito, que espero ya no esté temblando,
y como mi tiempo ya se me terminó,
ha sido estupendo hablarles
y regresen a trabajar, ¿de acuerdo?
(Aplausos)